في هذه المقبره بمدينه سانت بتروسبورغ
الروسيه دفن رئيس مجموعه فاجنر في جنازه
خاصه دون اي تكريم عسكري عشرات الاشخاص من
مجموعه فاجنر جاؤوا وهم واقاربهم لتوديع
بريكوجي اما الرئيس الروسي فقد تغيب عن
مراسم الدفن وفي موسكو تجمع السكان امام
نصب مرتجى للحداد من دون تواجد فاجنر على
الجبهه ستصبح الامور اكثر سوءا نحن في
حداد يا لها من خسارات
لنصلوا
للشعب الروسي لقد ضحوا بانفسهم لصالح
البلد
وكان بريكوجين قد لقي مصرعه مع اخرين من
مجموعه فاجنر عندما تحطمت بهم طائرات خاصه
الاربعاء الماضي بعد شهرين فقط من تمرد
مسلح قامت به المجموعه ضد قاده في الجيش
الروسي التحقيقات بشان الحادث لا تزال
مستمرا ومن بين الاسباب المحتمله انفجار
على متن طائره او ضربه صاروخيه اما
الكرملين فقد نفى اي تورط للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في هذا الامر